as more of this gets exposed their
nonsense and their corporate
coordination with big Tech and the
Democrats to silence you and confuse you
when it came to truth and honesty and
reality related to covet and so much
more that is crumbling in front of their
eyes right now so what do they have to
do they have to make sure that you think
that Elon and Twitter is a violent
attack on Democracy yeah so he was
posting pretty standard Q Anon pizzagate
cabal style stuff the idea that the
world is secretly run by this new world
order uh and it is trying to censor you
it's trying to prevent the world from
seeing what's really going on and that
Nancy Pelosi and people like that those
people in the Q Anon spaces right now
those people are at the top of that
sphere they are at the top of that
pecking order when it comes to how
people believe in conspiracy theories
and I do want to stress this
um
right now on trending on Twitter is the
lie about this guy it's the lie that
it's trending it's trending on Twitter
as we speak
uh because Elon Musk pushed it on
Saturday
or yesterday sorry uh I just want to
make it clear how they got to this place
so
uh I first of all lies on the internet
move faster than the truth and that's in
part why there are all these safeguards
that Elon Musk is trying to take down on
Twitter right now
um the lies that were pushed were from
Bad pieces of information they found for
example they said that uh Paul Pelosi
was uh in his underwear of course he was
2 30 in the morning at the time he was
attacked they that led them to believe
this was a lover's quarrel between two
different people that knew each other
the reason they believed they knew each
other is because the police put out a
statement saying that they didn't really
know who opened the door so they that
led them to believe there was a third
person in the house
there there was this World building on
the pro-trump internet what could be the
opposite of reality here
in the opposite reality they came up
with was these two people were having a
lover's quarrel in a house and the
police sort of intruded on us
it's fundamentally incorrect it was
pushed by the richest man in the world
and then yesterday it was pushed by
Donald Trump Jr who posted a picture of
underwear and a hammer and said it's a
Halloween costume for Paul Pelosi
if we don't cut this out right now not
just the normalization of violence but
the idea that reality can't even exist
anymore because it cannot catch up to
the lies on the internet
I'm not a scholar on authoritarian
history but I've let I've read Hannah
Wright I've read all of these people
this is how it gets really bad
this is the start of something that gets
really really bad if you are getting the
guardrails off the truth where it
literally cannot catch up to the lies on
the internet because of how the pipes
work how the system works because of the
incentives of the richest people in the
world
then that's how you lose your democracy
guys
this guy's freaking out about losing
democracy because of Q Anon and what
people are saying online that guy by the
way Ben Collins there his his title at
NBC News is he's on the dystopian beat
he's always looking for misinformation
he's one of the biggest Peddlers of
misinformation uh that exists right
because he's just doing it he has a
corporate desk so whatever he says is
misinformation is misinformation so
anyway Kyle Becker put out this awesome
list and here are some mainstream media
hoaxes that these people sitting at that
desk that MSNBC and the view and CNN and
Washington posted a whole bunch more put
out there you tell me how many of these
turned out to be true this is this is
fantastic